this report from our Middle East
correspondent Alistair bunkel coming up
does begin with CCTV of that car attack
last night
this is the moment Tel Aviv was hit by
another terrorist attack the driver an
Arab Israeli drove his car deliberately
towards people out enjoying their
evening by the beachfront the car drove
down this bike path the main road on one
side and the beachfront the other side
Gathering speed as it went along
and it hit these rocks bounced over them
and then lost control one person was
killed Alessandro perini a 35-yard
lawyer from Rome here on holiday
seven others were injured Italian and
British tourists but none seriously
this broken glass and the deep divots is
where the car hit the grass and at that
moment it flipped over now there are a
couple of Israeli police officers who
are in that petrol station they heard
what was going on they rushed out here
and they found the car upside down and
inside they say that the terrorists
reached for his gun and at that moment
they shot him dead
it was the second terrorist attack here
in a single day and another moment of
violence during this holiday period it's
really sad that
that tell the world was starting to be
like tourists that come to see the
beautiful country we have being part of
it and it's really a shame because we
just want to live peacefully I hope that
our government and the people on the
other side will understand that well
that we're all need to live together
here I feel worried it it's not easy
situation to be in that we need to look
behind our shoulders every time
the Prime Minister Benin Netanyahu has
ordered all Border Police reservists to
report for Duty from tomorrow
he has instructed his ministers to do
anything to avoid an escalation but when
things are as tense and on edge as they
are right now
the government is not always in control
of what happens next